Senators are supposed to be jurors in the
impeachment of a president.
And we learned that yesterday, 21
Republican senators, 21 of the 53 that's nearly
40% of the Republican senators left the Senate
chamber for long periods of time while Adam
Schiff was arguing the case of the prosecution
during yesterday's day of Donald Trump's Senate
impeachment trial.
Senators are supposed to be in their seats
during the trial.
They're supposed to not miss the proceedings
since this, these proceedings are what they
will ultimately be using to decide, are we
going to convict or are we going to acquit
the president of the United States?
And yet, 21 Republican senators and two democratic
senators were missing while Adam Schiff was
laying out the case.
They're not even pretending to take this seriously.
And of course, we know they're not taking
it seriously.
We know they've already decided that they
will be voting to acquit the president of
the United States, but they could at least
pretend to take it seriously.
Uh, Michael McAuliffe, who's a congressional
reporter, tweeted about this in the middle
of the day yesterday saying quote just counted
21 empty seats on the Republican side of the
Senate, two on the democratic side, a couple
of hours into Adam shifts presentation.
Some are just stretching their legs, but most
are not in the chamber.
Some of them have been out of there for a
while.
They're supposed to decide the fate of Donald
Trump based on the evidence and they are missing
the evidence.
And we talked, uh, on yesterday's livestream
of the proceedings about how chief justice
John Roberts, who's presiding over impeachment
as the chief justice of the Supreme court
does, John Roberts role is procedural.
It is not to evaluate the evidence or render
an opinion.
Part of the procedure that John Robert is
supposed to be enforcing are the basic rules.
Like senators must be there during the proceedings.
And this actually may be part of why we only
get two camera angles the entire time.
Seaspan has said they've requested to be allowed
to use their cameras in the Senate and to
control their cameras.
Mitch McConnell does not want that.
And when you look at the production of the
uh, stream, uh, unless something's changed
in the last few hours, there's a shot of the
outside of the Senate, which I believe is
still a C-SPAN camera.
And then there are two shots.
We get two camera angles.
There's like a zoomed in shot of the area
where Schiff and NAD learn the different,
um, house managers, uh, impeachment managers
stand.
And then there's a slightly wider shot that
lets you see the front of the room.
The tables were Donald Trump's defense attorneys
and the house impeachment managers in John
Roberts are pictured, but no real shots of
the chamber since we would all immediately
realize where the hell are the senators.
This is sick and disgusting.
And, and it is a sham.
Republicans have been saying this is a sham,
the right, it's a sham, but it's a sham because
40% of them are gone for long portions of
Adam's shifts and other presentations.
In a sense, it's almost as if there are 53
empty seats, right?
Because they're all, as far as we know, going
to vote to acquit Donald Trump regardless
of the evidence.
And like I said yesterday on Twitter, how
will they decide whether to convict or acquit
Trump if they don't see the testimony?
Oh, that's right.
They don't need to.
It's an absolute and total farce.
We're doomed in a sense here.
And this is not even really a matter of partisanship
per se.
It's just childish behavior.
It's immature elected officials.
It's a, uh, with a lot of them.
You know, we keep hearing it.
This is boring and uh, it's, it's boring.
But you are deciding about whether a president
who is only the third president ever to be
impeached is going to become the first president
ever to actually be convicted on impeachment.
And they're bored.
They're bored, and they're walking around
while Adam Schiff is presenting evidence.
It's a truly sorry bunch.
And because of the coverage on Fox news and
elsewhere, which I'm going to talk about momentarily,
a huge portion of the country will not even
hear that 40% of Republicans were gone during
much of Adam shift speech.
It won't even enter their echo chamber at
all ever, but it reinforces once again for
better or worse, our voicemail today argues
that this is for worse.
Every day of this reinforces that there's
one way to hold Donald Trump accountable.
I don't even have to say it.
We all know what it is and it would be done
in November.
Let me just put it that way.
It's nine and a half months away.
He won't be convicted on impeachment.
He's not going to be indicted criminally after
he's out of office.
Yesterday I got questions during our live
stream about how likely do you think it is
Trump gets indicted when he finally leaves
office?
I don't think it's likely at all.
I would not take that bet.
We have one shot to force him to suffer a
consequence and it's by voting him out in
November.
Let's now talk about Fox news as coverage.